I wanted to ask a question for for both
of you and Niko I guess you can go first
with this being your first experience in
the MCU how does it differ from your
previous films I know the scope and
scale of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
can be a bit daunting so how was your
approach to it yeah you know it was it
was it was pretty daunting
um I'm a big fan of the genre but have
never been a part of anything like this
so I really
um honestly I didn't know what to expect
how I guess I wasn't prepared just to
see how Grand of a scale it was all like
there were actual physical sets there
yeah it was it was I mean I was talking
to Miriam and and Chuck about this it's
all it was a lot like doing theater
because of the scale of the sets and
just
yeah the grandness of everything and
plus you know the characters that we
play sort of were very theatrical to
begin with so it really was sort of like
um you know in a previous life I used to
work um as a dresser for a theater
company so I for a Shakespeare Festival
no less so I really was kind of like oh
this Harkens me back to the days where I
would be backstage sort of like watching
these great Shakespearean actors perform
and I would just be in the back sort of
like watching you know and because Chuck
and Miriam were so amazing in portraying
these characters like I had to snap out
of it a couple of times to be like
you're in the scene with them like if
you're working right now like be present
be present
that's amazing what about you Miriam
it's true you know I'm a huge huge fan
of this particular genre as well so
like a dream come true it's like
suddenly you're a normal human adult and
the inner child who is like screaming
the entire time that you're on the set
that you get to actually play in this
sandbox you know you can't believe it
but you have to be professional so you
know
right which I don't know if I actually
achieved but I tried
um yeah it really it really was we were
on the carpet uh for the the premiere
and it was like the three of us like
hugging each other you know and and
Chuck was like it doesn't kind of matter
what you do this is like as this is kind
of as big as it gets you know I mean the
scale of this is all all around so like
enjoy it's like a nice yeah to like
remember to enjoy it because kind of
what's the point if you don't that
actually leads to another question that
I had since you both were talking about
your experience with Chuck right his his
presence on screen in this film is so
grandiose and so big the high
evolutionary I love how he's able to on
like a dime go from calm and collected
to just like insane as the film goes on
what was it like kind of matching that
energy or working off of him in those
scenes
well I feel it's kind of like when you
play tennis with someone who's really
good your game gets better
that's that I'm terrible at tennis no
matter what doesn't matter how good you
are I'm not good but in acting uh that's
kind of how it feels right like it gives
you permission to uh raise the stakes to
the highest level which is the most fun
way to do it you know and so
it's it everyone was so welcoming too
did you find that Nico yeah I'm afraid
to take
to go for it yeah and I think with with
James directing
um Chuck's character you know like like
Miriam said it was kind of like a game
of tennis you were you were all of a
sudden allowed to match this level and
match the evilness and match the
despicableness of the the world that we
were living in um we really took our
cues from from Chuck you know it was
that one
um the walk and talk scene that the
three of us did where truly like that
day I was like
I will feel his sleeping Amber just
emanating from him it's such a quiet
rage that lives inside the high
evolutionary and I really like felt like
it was like I think shock might kill me
when James yells cut uh
but yeah I also feel like how we did a
lot of takes and I was like have we
walked like 15 miles down this model
I was like I'm really getting like my
workout today's a leg day yeah
yeah oh I was so nervous that's the I
was so nervous for that scene I I don't
know if you remember I kept like popping
my lines and I was like I'm sorry I
swear to God I've done this before no
but I feel like it was the actual
Network so well for the energy because
the truth is this is a person who will
create and Destroy on a whim yeah yes so
I mean I'm sure we've all had bosses
like that
um
Disney Plus show we need right there yes
one of the most standout scenes in the
film for me is as we we're seeing more
of the high evolutionary you and the
other people in the room eventually turn
your guns on the high evolutionary what
was it like reading that part of the
script when you're like oh we're gonna
have a small revolt
mutiny
or boiling it uh
yes those are good
then I just disappear and you never hear
from me again no um I I no that moment
are you kidding me that was a fantastic
but I read that moment I was like
I'm taking my I'm taking over the
oh my god
um
it was like uh
that's the that's the scene you play in
that's the scene I've played in like
every basement and backyard since I was
six years old you know what I mean and I
was getting to do it
so it was
it was beautiful I was I was very very
excited
um to do that you know and it doesn't
quite go as she planned yeah
it's not the longest she could still put
it on a resume though but it's not the
longest job she's ever held
um the captain of the ship that great
turning turning point too and also look
I could write a dissertation on the all
these movies I over intellectualize
everything because it just makes it fun
for me and I'm a Sci-Fi nerd and that's
what we do so I was like this is really
that moment when the person who's been
following the leader
into the worst possible place over the
worst possible Cliff has that moment
right before of like wait where why you
know what am I doing and that moment of
questioning because we've seen
these these leaders can go nowhere
without followers
and so what what allows a person
to follow a leader the worst possible
leader and and when is the what is that
moment like for them when they realize
oh my God I'm
I've LED myself off the cliff like I've
followed this person off the cliff and
so that moment was kind of fun to play
where you're like yeah bring on the
brakes nope too late yeah
yeah
I think that's what I mean at least the
way I saw the quarter teal was like you
know he was for teal it was like
survival at any cost which is why he
kept following
um the high evolutionary and just
following his orders and just being so
loyal to him but then he would be um the
cause of our demise which
I think it's so ironic that um yeah
that's that's how we that's how we go
because of them we're running out of
time here but uh Nico I did have one
more question for you uh regarding to
you
you become like the fixation for
Star-Lord once he finds out you can
possibly get him the files to save
rocket what was it like
when you had to go against Star-Lord and
brute like they got really intense there
it got very intense that scene was also
such a big
um day of shooting
um and it was the most fun because you
had you know we were shooting Parts with
Chuck and Miriam and then Parts with
with me and and Chris Pratt and and
Groot and then you had all the guards
and the other the other recorders it was
like I don't know it was just like a
such a fun day on set because you got to
see the full sort of like this is a
Marvel production and we are gonna have
the stunts and explosions and and the
CGI like like everything was sort of
just like happening that day and so I
was just like bring it I'm I'm like
literally living my dream right now and
we are filming like this huge Marvel CNN
I don't know it was sort of kind of like
an out-of-body experience I was kind of
just watching it from from high above
because it's like I cannot believe this
is happening no I know as a fan you're
like how do they make this oh this is
how they do it okay exactly that's
exactly it was like yeah thank you so
much for your time it's been a blast hi
thank you